did you see uh recently i mean he was on
his podcast a couple weeks ago and he
said that he would he would fight you
for free or some [ __ ] maybe no no no no
he oh he's cat he's catching he said
some [ __ ] like that i'm by the way i
might be totally i listened to the
podcast
and he had said like um
that there's no like
real beef between you guys but if he had
to do like a celebrity fight
yeah
who whatever you gotta do with celebrity
fight what you guys each getting 500k
you're doing the fight yeah that's the
fact i i don't
[ __ ] beat people up for less funny
than enough for nothing yeah what's up
like where where was the uh i mean you
guys have kind of had like a nice snow
with nothing with him
a little riff for a while now you juggy
joe like amazed whatever i don't get
but you know i don't got no b for nobody
in the new year 2010 that's good yeah
that's good especially like in the
podcast space because
i like
i don't want to say i i don't use the
term respect loosely but like if every
like people that are doing [ __ ] like how
you doing this podcast academics like
junkie joe like a bunch of people doing
these [ __ ] i i say it endearingly like
[ __ ] he was a junkie but it's okay a lot
of junkies it's all right long as you
get better but anyway
you know like [ __ ] is doing
some [ __ ] that all right so this is dope
let me try let me aspire to do this so i
give credit where credit is due
um all and and [ __ ] this man other
people doing [ __ ] yeah it's a lot of
dope pocket i feel like i'm forgetting
somebody man